لم يعد كذلك فمياهه العذبه اصبحت ملوثه
بشكل شبه كامل تعددت الاسباب والنتيجه
واحده مياه غير صالحه للاستخدام او الشرب
تسعون في المئه نسبه التلوث في نهر دجله
هذا ما اعلنته وزاره البيئه العراقيه رقم
صادم جعل موضوع التلوث على سلم اولويات
الوزاره لوضع خطط عاجله للحد من خطورته
اشاره البيئه باعتبارها وزاره اشرافيه
تبذل جهود جديه لالزام الجهات الملوثه
باتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه للمحافظه على
المصادر المائيه من التلوث هنالك لجنه
عليا لمواجهه تاثير او مواجهه استمرار
تلوث المصادر المائيه يتراسها معالي وزير
البيئه وعضويه كل الجهات هذه اللجنه عملت
خارطه الطريق بخطط قصيره ومتوسطه وطويله
الامد
بشكل جدي على تقليل احمر التلوث للمصادر
المائيه الدكتوره اقبال لطيف المتخصصه
بالتلوث البيئي تؤكد من خلال ابحاثها ان
نهري دجله والفرات ملوثان بنسبه تامه ولا
يصلحان للاستخدام البشري كما هو الحال مع
نهر ديالا وبحر النجف من خلال توثيق
للواقع البيئي في نهر دجله ونهر الفرات
ونهر دياله وبحر النجف وجدت ان هناك تلوث
عالي بنسبه 100% في نهر دجله و100% في نهر
الفرات وهذا التلوث هو لا يصلح للاستهلاك
البشري ولا الاستهلاك الحيواني ولا يصح
ايضا للري خطورتها هذه تكمل انه في حاله
ارتفاع الصيف في الارتفاع درجات الحراره
يحدث التبخر ويزيد من تركيز هذه العناصر
الثقيله
الملوثات الطبيه والصناعيه التي ترمى بشكل
مستمر من دون رادع في نهر دجله تجعل منه
بيئه خصبه لانتشار الامراض ما لم يتم
علاجها بشكل جدي خاصه في فصل
الصيفرات ممكن انه نلاحظ كميات ملوثه
بالقرب من مدينه الطب ممكن انه نلاحظ هناك
كثير من التلوث في المياه هذا يحتاج مثل
ما اسلفنا الى وحدات معالجه وحدات معالجه
حقيقيه وحديثه انه ليس تكون فقط هذه
الوحدات المعالجه تكون على الورق لكن يجب
ان تطبيق هذه المشاريع وفق خطط استراتيجيه
حديثه حتى تخدم البيئه العراقيه
مع هذه النسب المخيفه من التلوث لا يزال
العراقيون يعتبرون ان هذا النهر شريان
حياتهم
ومتنفسهم الوحيد سامر الكبيسي العربيه
بغداد لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات